foreign
[Music]
it recently became known that various
spin-off projects for the Fast and
Furious franchise are in development and
now we got the first details one of the
biggest stars of the series is not only
coming back but is also getting a
standalone film we're talking about
Dwayne Johnson Alias Luke Hobbs after
months of back and forth we finally
learned that he is back for Fast and
Furious 11. and things keep moving as
the rap could exclusively bring to light
Universal is developing an entire film
around Johnson's character the movie is
to link the current part of the fast
series with its sequel thus it is
explicitly not a continuation of the old
spin-off Fast and Furious Hobbs and Shaw
from 2019 even if the same screenwriter
Chris Morgan is involved the rock also
announced the movie with big words on
Twitter he had settled the dispute with
Vin Diesel last summer and he added that
he was overwhelmed by the positive
response to fast X and that the audience
always comes first for him there is no
release date for The Fast and Furious
Luke Hobbs Solo movie yet but if it is
to hit theaters before Fast and Furious
11 production should get started soon we
will keep you up to date as always
foreign
[Music]